[Music]
so
we're starting the podcast cool are you
guys in wear hats the whole time
uh i have a really bad hairline he just
got his fixed i just got my fix but i
still so is the hat holding it
in no it's not holding it in i just
don't like my hair yet
so you because you got a hair transplant
yeah is the hat
holding the stitches in no it's not i
just i'm not happy with it still
he's about a year post-op okay yeah okay
so you're
wearing the hat to cover your hairlines
no i'm not saying take it off i'll show
it i'll show it if we're
doing it i want to know we get granular
on this podcast and we deconstruct
things that seem like minutiae but
they're not
so are you wearing them because you're
insecure because you're trying to sell
merch
because you're like i would just want to
know insecure
insecure this is not my brand okay this
is just the only outside fit in my head
okay so you're both insecure about your
hairlines yeah that's like the only
thing i'm insecure about
i feel like yeah that it it's such a
weird thing i didn't know like other
people felt it
too and then we started talking about it
we found other people that were like
wow no i want to get a transplant too
and like i didn't know it was such a
common thing
but it's so powerful because you know
nobody talks about male insecurity
they only talk about female insecurity
that's what dominates the narrative
yeah and why don't you guys get more
attention for this are you
do you was it hard for you to admit you
were insecure about that
i don't think so not me i've always been
like but is this next generation able to
say
i'm scared i'm insecure i'm fearful yeah
100 i feel like i i
definitely showed that like i showed my
entire hair uh hair transplant surgery
process
do you think you would have done it if
you weren't able to get it for content
do you know what i mean was getting it
for content part of what made you
able i think the content is what helped
pay for it yeah it's i
i would not be able to afford that so
it's almost like this
new thing where we are always rolling
and recording everything we do
yeah it's the same thing that creates
our insecurities
are kind of helping heal them right
being seen
and rejected is what we're afraid of but
being seen and exposing
the most embarrassing parts of ourselves
right and i think
i think a big thing about it is like
calling out your own insecurities before
other people do
that's a big thing that's what stand up
is they say yeah comedians
we become comedians to control how we're
embarrassed
yeah and because you feel like this is
a big part of what you do is like a
defense mechanism
in a way of like i'm going to make fun
of myself before you can yeah i go hard
too
we go hard before we let anybody else
take control what are you scared of
were you bullied no no no never about
you're about to be
for the next two hours uh i just like i
just don't like the way like i look
without a hat on
i just like i i just feel really like
weird without it
i have like super thin hair mm-hmm and
then it's also like
tucking back a little bit men in their
hair are like women in their tits right
yeah i feel like hair is all like a guy
has and dick hair and dick
hair and dick and feet size and height
see here's the thing is like
this is a hot take the hot take
is that women actually have it slightly
easier in terms of our
unrealistic and possible body standards
because
we can change ours we can get hair
extensions we can wear high heels
we can wear makeup you guys can't all
the things
that you're expected to have to be big
and perfect
are genetically locked it's height
hairline
dick size yep and now i only have one of
those
so and that's hair now
[Laughter]
let's talk about the hair on your dick
in a minute
so do you think that part of your
why people are so enamored with you is
that you've
shown your vulnerabilities yeah i think
so i feel like all of us in our
group yeah we that's all we do is we
always make fun of ourselves we
we like put a spotlight on what we feel
the worst about ourselves and
we yeah make a joke out of it because i
want to add
throw some context in here not that we
ever do this in a linear way
people know how my mind works by now but
it occurred to me this morning that you
guys
are um
friends right you are to your generation
what the tv show friends was to mine
oh i thought you meant like us in
general we are friends i was like yeah
yeah
but i'm glad i saw you be full of shit
in that moment
i'm glad i saw you be faking that right
right but yeah until you make it baby
but i mean like you guys are the next
generations the tv show friends
yeah right so you're david who's david
schwimmer who's ross
who's i'm like the drunk idiot so
whichever
one that is chandler maybe chandler no
that's just matt perry in real life oh
i feel like i feel like i would uh
gravitate and identify with chandler
fair enough fair enough yeah so
i cause i don't i don't totally know you
guys
which is what makes this incredibly
surreal
we got a couple hours to learn yeah so
how do you know me we we do have a pass
together
yeah in some way let him take the wheel
okay yeah
i told zayn this earlier and he was like
no way um so
i've been like a fan of yours for a long
time
uh the show whitney was our family tv
show that we would watch
[Laughter]
and it was like we would all sit down
and watch it every week
you have a fucked up family and he's not
lying because i like i've seen i've seen
you
watch this show before like so is this
weird for you
um not weird i'm more excited like i
told my parents they're like no way
like that's so cool wow um so so it is
cool what about that show
i don't know it was just like i thought
it was just really funny
yeah no i mean that show it's it's weird
for me to say this and it sounds
self-aggrandizing narcissistic like
i'm the fir i literally wrote a book and
make a podcast
talking about my flaws and all the
things i'm bad at and do wrong
i just posted on instagram today myself
trying out new materials that
new material that wasn't working i'm the
first person to say when something isn't
isn't funny and when i did something
right and wrong
that show was fucking hilarious and
it got killed because i became this um
i now see it what happened like i became
this like
martyr of like all of the this um
just like latent hatred towards loud
women
i was like very triggering to people i
now look back and i'm able to do it
without emotion like i can zoom out and
go like i really just
triggered people and i i can kind of see
why an eating disorder at the time i was
really really skinny
um crystalia was on the show
um and you know it
it triggered people but in hollywood at
least
people didn't like that outsiders made
it
chris dalia and i were outsiders and we
made it
and this is what you guys are also
like that in a way it kind of felt like
the beginning of the outsiders coming
into hollywood and eclipsing hollywood
that's what you guys are doing because
you're displacing us you know like
you're the new guard
and krista lee and i nobody knew who we
were we weren't famous
that was like your your first like huge
big first thing i've ever done gotcha
and we
i wrote a script from my friend
crystalia who i did comedy with every
night
we did this sitcom we were fucking
around the way you guys make your
youtube videos
we were literally just make cracking
each other up
filming it right and then it tested so
highly this is just a true
science fact not me um having high
self-esteem because we know that's not
my brand
it tested so highly that it got the
biggest ad campaign
nbc's ever done wow it was ubiquitous
it was like i don't know you were
probably too young to really remember
the ad campaign
it was just kind of it was like on
popcorn bags at movie theaters like if
you open the dvd
you don't know what that is there should
be these things called dvds you open a
dvd of bridesmaid and an
ad for the show whitney would come out
like that's how much money they put
behind it
and i know that when
other people get wild success and
i make fun of them it's because i'm
jealous or it hurts me or it makes me
think they have it i can't get it you
know like i think i just
yeah chris lee and i kicked up a lot of
that in
in in sort of the hollywood culture
we weren't we didn't we weren't cast as
actors by writers that wrote it we did
it
was it was it something that you guys
wrote and you were just like ah let's
see if we could like film it and pitch
it and then like you're like oh
shit it worked yes we were trying to
youtube wasn't around yet
we were trying to do what you guys are
doing yeah but we didn't have the
literal we didn't have youtube or the
bandwidth we had like
vimeo was maybe happening but we didn't
have cameras we didn't have phones with
camera you know so we kind of did a
youtube show
on network television so if like if
you're making
if you're making that show today would
you have tried to put that on youtube
now or would you still try to like if we
did it today
i would call you guys and say what do
you think i should do
whoa okay and that's not only no one
else for
because you guys frankly know more than
i do about this space
yeah you know it used to be like if you
wanted to make something if you want to
make art if you want to connect with
people if you wanted to put on a play
for people
you had to go to all these
old guys old businessmen
beg them to give you permission to put
on your play
yeah and probably make you change
everything that you well
what do you know about what it's like to
be a 26 year old
girl with a bad childhood nothing so
you're going to tell me
you just want to fuck me you just want
me to be someone you'd want to fuck
but i'm loud and big and complicated and
imperfect and obnoxious and so they just
want to
make you leah remini in um
king of queens yeah they want you to
just sort of um
be a stepford wife so um we used i'd
have to just go like daddy please can i
and you guys just broke that yeah you
guys
i i this is going to sound like um
i'm being anxious or something but
what you guys have done has like healed
the artists and the broken performers
that have been trying to connect
with people you removed the gatekeepers
that were
stopping us from being able to heal
ourselves
yeah that's a good way to put it that's
awesome though i mean but yeah it is
cool
and especially with like the technology
now like anybody can do
like a youtube and make like a video um
and i feel like what's what makes it
go viral and not um humor is it emotion
is it people being invested in you i
think it's what's to do with all those
the common denominator
well i think it's just like if you
yourself are so interested in the
content you're making there's gonna be
people
that find it interesting and worth
watching also
i feel like a lot of people go into
youtube and they think like i want to be
a youtuber just because they want to be
they see like i guess like the good life
or whatever it is um
and they don't genuinely want to make
the videos they don't want to do
they're just trying to pretend everyone
knows everything and it's easy it's easy
to differentiate that when you like look
at all these creators you like you know
exactly who's doing it just for that and
actually no one's getting away with
anything anymore
yeah the days of people getting away
with anything are over yeah
so you guys broadcast your
vulnerabilities
things that people would normally hide
back in my day
we hid those things we kept secrets we
pretended
you can't do that do you think it was a
choice to broadcast
your insecurities and share all this or
did you just
know you wouldn't be able to get away
with it um no i think
like i know that's i know that's a weird
question yeah i don't think i minded
like for me i didn't mind at all i feel
like it's important to show people that
you can be vulnerable and you can't tell
people that you you you think your
hairline sucks and you want a hair
transplant and
it's and while you're doing it be funny
about it let people know that hey it's
okay
that your fucking hairline sucks a lot
of people's hair sucks so just
get the procedure done let people know
let men know that like hey it's okay to
get your hairline done if you don't
think it's okay and then
but also i'm hearing this
narrative hearing seeing that there's
this thing called toxic masculinity
and that this next generation of boys is
toxic because they watch too much porn
and they hate women and they're not in
touch with their feelings
and that's not what i'm seeing you
broadcasting like you guys
it's weird anathema to that yeah it's
weird because i feel like
um when you talk about like toxic
masculinity i feel like
now it's getting the opposite i was just
i feel like
yes it's it's like it's femininity yeah
my 20s it like i feel like the guys were
trying to be super masculine and like
but now it's like i mean you like look
at like tik tok like the biggest guys
are kind of feminine in the way that
they
uh and let's define masculine and define
feminine because then we then it gets
wild
right and it did what does that even
mean
because yeah because vulnerability what
i saw i watched your video this morning
of you getting your hair transplant yeah
and i was just fascinated what what does
that mean
i'm really scared does that make you
scared yourself baby i watched your
video oh fuck
why like what does that make you feel
what does that bring up
um no i'm i kind of forgot what i had in
there no it's just
like i sometimes i say stupid things
while i'm filming but uh
why wouldn't you you're 20. exactly yeah
i'm i'm not 20. i'm joking
i'm 27 i'm 28. um what was the question
though that you're asking me basically
like what
happens when i say i saw your video this
morning about you
uh getting a hair transplant um what
happens
because your body language kind of
tightened up a little no shit okay no i
i i know what it is i don't think i like
people i know watching my stuff yeah
you don't know me i do know you now and
and i like and i respect you too and i
think you're hilarious so to me it's
just like oh fuck why
she's watching my thing it's interesting
i have that too where when i
when i'm it took me so long to embrace
social media and such because
i was always posting for other comedians
and i had shame and i was embarrassed
but that's not who we're doing this for
that's not who pays our bills i don't
pay your bills
yeah it's not for me right i'm not your
fan base
i'm a fan of yours but i'm not anything
you have i'll get for free
you'll send me your merch for free i'm
not buying your merch i'm going to get
it comped you know what i'm saying
but that's fascinating to me because
like when you're in the process of
making these videos
who are you envisioning that they're for
um
it's kind of the same feeling where like
i don't like somebody's watching one of
my videos
in front of me like that to me is the
worst because like
which is wild it's like they have a
pressure to think something is funnier
or to look more interested and then
there's like always some sort of like
yeah fakeness to it where you're like oh
it was like a sympathy laugh or so
that's your that's impostor syndrome so
you have imposter syndrome yeah i was
actually i was just talking about this
with you
when i so i got invited to uh do
drake's last music video which is
unbelievable i don't know why i got
asked but
you know why you got asked why did you
get asked baby you're
you're super they wanted they wanted me
to be the comedic relief of the music
video
it was like justin bieber and his like
entourage hold on slow down
why are you rushing through this i'm i'm
rushing through it because i don't think
it like matters do you have
you're embarrassed about how successful
you are no no
no you're right it is fucking impostor
syndrome i feel like you're rushing
through
because you don't want to sound like
your brother you're being my therapist
it's like a fucking session but you're
you're you have
shame you're you're talking fast always
what does the shame come from i because
so there's a lot of times where i feel
like i don't like deserve a lot of
things but then i've
you were it doesn't help when i see like
some people online saying you don't
deserve all this so i take that and i'm
just like great
you're right i don't deserve so but um
why do you believe them
what's going on with you that you think
they're right oh shit
i just we i feel like we just we love to
take negative comments and put it in our
head and instead of
we amplify them yeah we amplify them
which is part of the reason why you're
so successful is because that's the way
your brain works
so that has served you really well but
like it's an
it's um something you have to learn how
to turn on and off because it's not
serving you right now
yeah you know i mean
yeah because i mean how many followers
do you have millions and millions of
you you these guys drove up in a blue
lamborghini to my home i have a blue
lamborghini in my driveway
you didn't see his white lamborghini in
front of mine oh yeah
you have a white lamborghini i've never
i don't know are these concept cars like
i haven't even seen these on the road
before this is
these are space vehicles it's the suv
one so it it looks
it doesn't look like crazy it's the suv
one so you can't you can barely tell
it's a lamborghini no
yes you can tell
so yeah so i'm just saying you have a
lamborghini
yeah which how much proof do you need
that you deserve to what you have i
think
for me when i think about like if i have
imposter syndrome
i mean i'm glad you have it by the way
it's not it's why i like you
it's not that i feel like i don't just
like i know i worked hard to be where i
am
i i just feel guilty interesting is the
most useless emotion
i know but i just feel like
does it drive you do you use it is it
part of your engine is it yeah
i have like this i don't even know what
it is
always wanting to better myself like i
don't like being stuck or plateauing
like i want to keep
yeah driving myself to do more and more
and better things
um but i just a part of me feels like
when i take a step back i'm super
grateful for my life my friends
everything that i have but i feel guilty
sometimes when i'm looking at it i'm
like
do you give to others yeah
you're a good person i'd like to think
i'm a good person mm-hmm
i'll let you know what heath is saying
there's times where like it'll be a day
of wake up where i'm just like i feel
like just giving everything i haven't
just giving away to my family i'm just
like you know what i'm just trying to
find a regular job
because i don't want to do this anymore
it's so interesting so you've worked
your ass off
to achieve this impossible um
spot in rarefied air and you're
here you have it all and you feel guilty
what a shame and yay great
like like in like my house like i would
like walk around and i'll just be like
i don't need all this like i don't i
think that's like i don't need it
yeah but you are healing a lot of people
what you do brings joy to a lot of
people
you're connecting to a lot of people
right and anesthetizing them
you guys are drugs you're drug dealers
right
that's a good way okay i feel better now
now being a drug dealer makes it seem
better that i have
yeah so let's talk about your personal
life
yes okay let's do it how old are you uh
27. uh-huh
28 27 27 28. so
to me the only thing more interesting
about you than the fact that you're
famous youtube stars is the fact that
you're just
27 and 28 year old boys like i feel like
i'm
an anthropologist like i never get to
see you guys thankfully
um you're way too old for me um
what's going on you date your editor
i wanna i wanna know what you think of
women i wanna know how you
fuck okay i wanna know everything oh you
wanna
work i wanna know what's going on with
sex in your
generation okay okay i wanna know if
porn has broken you
fixed you healed you helped you cool um
i'll start off with yes i'm dating my
editor or my
girlfriend is now my editor as it should
be
she's incredible i'm just saying editors
uh we were talking about this
outside editors should be women
women were the first editors because
film
so crazy rolls of film you know there
used to be actual roles of film in the
big like tin boxes
and they had little little um what is it
when the edges are perforated
and they would cut them and sew them and
so women used to edit feature films
because it was the most like sewing
could you imagine us trying to make a
youtube video right now we're just like
there is
and women i mean we are better at
details i'm sorry these
little tiny like editing is essentially
untangling a necklace it's a rubik's
cube
puzzle yes it's a puzzle that's how she
feels about it and women are uniquely
qualified to
sort of do it because i always wonder i
always wondered how she like learned
so quickly yeah she knows exactly what
we want cutting and sewing it's cutting
and sewing
yeah it's amazing it's putting together
a vision board i taught her and
the next day she was already better at
editing than i was taught herself
well i showed her you talked i showed
her fuck out of here
she i mean she don't think she's ever
edited the video before yeah
but i showed her like the buttons and
she was like okay cool i got this
yeah and then she apparently knew how to
do it phenomenal
yeah a woman's place is in the editing
room can you
not gargling are you doing an asmr video
for your channel right now
for a bottle of water oh my god what
what
is are we in an ad are we in on your
podcast
oh my god you scoot over one of those
like big water jugs with like
what is happening by the way quick story
for a month and a half
i thought this was a gallon water jug so
every day i was like
gotta drink a gallon of water that's my
goal whoa i'm fucking healthy now and
it's half a gallon for a month and a
half i've been drinking
water that's still a good amount that's
not a good amount a gallon isn't good
enough there's a good amount
of water i just had to throw that out
there he wants to show how healthy he is
yeah
no huge health kick right now we're both
losing weight
we're trying are you insecure about your
body incredibly why
um i don't feel comfortable looking at
myself and i think growing up i got made
fun of a lot for it
um you did yeah i went to a summer camp
that was
called aquatics did you really not know
that are you just asking for content no
i i didn't i actually
you didn't know he's been made fun of no
i didn't because he's the one usually
making fun of me
um yes as a kid like i grew up in a
water camp
in a water camp yeah it was like a
summer camp that was at a pool
so we were just in the water every day
it's just called camp
no because there was the camp next door
to us that never really went in the pool
and they were more like sports geared
okay swim you went to swim camp
that sounds traumatic um there was a
couple other big boys
i was like husky husky but i so was i i
was a husky husky kid
and so did you overeat
the yes i did overeat i have an older
brother and he was like football star
major jock athlete guy youngest yeah and
he's seven years older than me so at the
time you're a mistake
i don't know i've never asked my parents
seven years is a big
yeah big gap no one that's not a plan
that's not planned but i would have
thought i'd come back
and find out i'm a mistake can i tell
you i mean it's very common
that not only the youngest is usually
super as my mom calls it a surprise
uh mistake uh becomes an overachiever
to basically justify their existence
because they know
that they have to earn their keep
interesting yeah
so that's part of your drive right too
i'm the second kid
are you the youngest it was oh yeah for
sure fuck okay
yeah no one wants more than one kid my
mom told me that if she had me first
they wouldn't had a second
she's always told me that yeah you see
i'd be i'd be like
my son or daughter needs like a friend
so you were
an accident and then you over
compensated by coming becoming rich and
famous i mean
thanks mom i just mean you earned your
keep
you earned your place she doesn't regret
you anymore
anymore now that you have a blue
views all right things are working out
she's probably sitting there when's my
lamborghini right right i'm just trying
to figure out how this was all
made how your brains and genetics uh
made you these special people
are you ready you want to you want to
tell her let's do it uh-oh
what are we about to let out
like you're like you know how to not cut
each other off
we're trying is it because you know that
it's going to look like shit when you
subtitle it
yeah yeah we we because we used to cut
each other off all the time
on our podcast but we've been learning
slowly and subtly not to do it so we
don't do it anymore
you just cut me off no i was completing
it
that's how i stopped interrupting people
is that it got so fucking annoying
to sorry what was that
you just unplugged everything i moved
around a lot your condom just fell off
are you wearing a condom yes i brought
one just in case i didn't know how this
was gonna go
if we have sex i'm going to want your
sperm
okay um there you go how much longer is
this
um fascinating so do you guys feel like
your personalities are kind of
being ordained by
filming yourselves does that make sense
um you're becoming better people because
you're constantly under surveillance in
post-production on your own
personalities
i don't think so but you stopped
interrupting each other you stopped
doing something very rude
for a mercenary reason which is that
i don't want to have the subtitle look
like to look like shit for my business
i think it was more just like it's hard
to follow and it honestly like it just
doesn't sound good
and our friend group we all stopped
doing something rude
because it didn't sound good in your
business
it's not rude to us that we cut each
other off because we don't do it we
don't do it like
respect it's not disrespectful right
yeah and like when we hang out like a
group setting like our friends we're all
just like
chiming in and it's just a very like
high energy back and forth banter
so we're just like we get excited
because we just like
like talking about stuff not once have
we ever gone and said
yo you cut me off like those words like
so do you ever fight
not really surprising we used to like i
feel like we used to fight a little back
then but i feel like
because this is all so new and we're
just trying to figure out like if you
could change anything about him what
would it be
um there's a lot you can change about me
you could just say it
i would say being a better listener
nice there's a difference between
listening and hearing yes
like you want them to listen to what you
say or hear what you say
to interpret what i'm saying are you
communicating responsibly and directly
and clearly
yes so when you say something to him you
don't think he hears you
i think he hears my voice talking i
don't think he's processing what i'm
saying sometimes
because you think he's waiting like
thinking of a joke
or thinking of his response thinking
ahead yeah that's a bummer 100 i do that
i don't do i do that on the podcast or i
do that like all the time in person
oh okay fuck um no your relationships
with women
do you date women you date women yeah
good yeah uh
i mean not good i was right um good
thank you
she's like nailed that one
plot to us whitney's homophobic who are
you dating now
i'm not dating anybody right now what's
that like um it's very lonely
you don't want to um you couldn't i'm
i'm back and forth all the time like
especially
like during these times i i do want to
be with someone especially since all my
friends are dating
or like or with somebody how did your
last relationship end
um not very good what happened um
not very well one thing i don't want to
talk about that is like only one thing i
don't want to talk about
because i can't because if i because if
we talk about it then it's just going to
open up
i respect that so you understand you uh
boundaries you have good self-care and
good boundaries yeah that's good
i think it's really important to show
people if you don't want to talk about
something you can just say
i don't want to talk about that yeah i'm
not mad at you it made me like you more
than you just did that
thank you i think it's really important
to show that to people i've never done
that before i've never been like we
can't talk about that that was yeah
first time ever
and i'm me you did it to me on my
podcast i know i feel really bad about
it too
you shouldn't i'm gonna drive home be
like are you having we call that after
burn are you having afterburn no
guilt shame no you did the right thing
yeah i did no i i know i definitely did
the right thing that was a positive
contribution to your future self
yeah it was and that was the best thing
you could have done for your future
girlfriend what
is your future girlfriend no baby there
you go
your future girlfriend slash wife will
see this one day
and it would have been such a bummer if
you had over shared that was very
respectful so all you listeners
what do you want what do you want what i
want uh i
what do i want are you ready for your
claire underwood uh
kind of yeah i think in like kind of
yeah in a couple months you're my
nightmare
because in a couple months what's gonna
change in a couple months your
hairline's gonna heal
it's still coming in it is it's actually
two more months until it's fully
fully grown out but he then i have so
much going on or about a star going on
right now
so i feel like we're pretty booked out
in like two months i'll be available so
you want to schedule
your soulmate you're scheduling yourself
no no i'm definitely the type where like
if it happens it happens for sure but if
you should know not to uh
hit that table uh because it's fucking
up the sound you of all people should
know not to do that
come on mr respect if you gave me
an uh an option uh-huh i'd take the
option of
not right now in two months fuck yeah
let's do it i'm holding up
these public goods products hand soap
this came in the mail
because i never had it before and it's
like the most visually
soothing item i have in my home look at
the back of it
look at all the facts on the back of it
this we're working on a face oil
packaging this is the kind of packaging
i like benton
it's simple it's clean it's not
triggering it's not yelling at me it's
not distracting me it's not clashing
with anything that i already have
my problem with basic goods in your
house
is that you spend all this time
decorating your house you spend all this
money
all this mental energy and then you put
a clean you try to clean your floor
or you try to clean your dishes or you
try to wash your hands and then the hand
soap
ruins all the work you've done by being
loud
and obnoxious in neon yellow and orange
and screaming at you with exclamation
cleaning products have like exclamation
marks on them like why are you yelling
at me
yeah but not these these are little
pieces of art but these excite me they
look like they're in the mall
from the moma gift shop i think they're
exciting though too
because they all look alike because
they're and i like opening a package
where i feel like everything is
streamlined
they're cohesive they're like a family
they're all oh my god different rooms in
my home i'm like look at all my things
that i bought at one time
they everything so explain this even the
food follows this trend
so they make basics right
they search the globe to find clean
healthy eco-friendly and innovative
products like sulfate free shampoo
hand sanitizer which i'm holding right
now clean
simple free paper products and i will
say
um they're really big into oh right here
yeah they're really big into making sure
their products are healthy and safe for
humans animals and the environment
i mean yeah i mean and i mean heaven
they also offer you you pay a membership
and then you can shop through them and
everything is like
a couple dollars really like everything
like like the razer blades are one
dollar
so and they're great so they just have
basics
it's it's these staples staples and they
have this like
very just streamed line aesthetic that
makes me feel like i'm in the future
it's very minimalistic doesn't it feel
like you're in um
uh ex machina like he would have these
for me
the guy from ex machina would have these
in his bathroom for me it makes me feel
like someone who lives
in like tuscany and has a beautiful
clean
simple and look it says it's all good on
it it just it's just
me i'm a very tactile person i like
touching things i'm very visual
this doesn't ruin your house these
products don't
ruin your house more about the by being
a eyes an eyesore most clean most basic
products are an eyesore
also every time you make an order you
get the option to pick one free product
to try
so like and then they change it up every
time so like i got hot sauce one time i
did it
i got hair pomade one time and i was
like well
who knows this will be good and it was
it's probably the best airplanes i own
you know what i love that's kind of like
at the at the you know when like we used
to go to stores and at the buzzer they'd
have like
stuff at the end and you would just grab
stuff that you didn't really know you
even needed
you know it's almost like that goes and
they have ramen noodles you were telling
me they have really good ramen noodles
they're very good and they're not like
they feel like you're eating like that
traditional college this is my ramen but
they're like
a thick it's they're kind of new you
would get if you go to a ramen
restaurant they're like scrub
they're more scrumptious and higher
quality yeah and they yeah
they're very they're very cinematic and
ig
friendly they're made for making a meal
yeah
not for fulfilling it they're hearty
they feel very like yeah they're really
really delicious they actually sell out
a lot because they're so good
we worked out an exclusive deal just for
the good for you podcast listeners hold
these up receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase
i'm using the that's right they're so
confident that you absolutely love their
product and come back again and again
that they are giving you 15 dollars
to spend on your first purchase you have
nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com
whitney or use code whitney at checkout
that is public
p u b l i c goods g o
o d dot com forward slash whitney to
receive 15
off your first order excellent made in
the usa
fuck yeah i don't know about you but my
default emotion is perspiration
i am a sweater i sweat it's all i do
i slept when i'm happy when i'm sad when
i'm nervous you know what's weird about
this i sweat in the shower that's not
normal i just want you guys to know i
know it
sounds like benton's reading off
something but he's not when benton talks
it
sounds like he's reading something
that's been written that's how
like funny you are i sweat a lot
you can attest to this right i have to
sit outside sometimes while whitney gets
ready because i sweat
you know what i'm not sweating making
this ad come in under a minute
listen i'm telling you the reason i'm
i'm bringing up how much i sweat is so
you know that this product works because
i'm that person who's like
ugh natural deodorant like watch me be
somewhat small like patchouli and sweat
all day
no this you are dry you are dry you are
sweat free you don't smell bad but
you're jumping
you're jumping ahead yeah you're jumping
ahead you're holding the product
thank you i know but some people listen
to this some people don't watch it on
youtube some people are listening
okay please make a montage of all the
times we set the product
first you know what you're sweating so
much during this ad read i'm gonna give
you a native deodorant is this my
favorite one coconut vanilla that's my
goat
put this all over your face right now
sometimes i think about rubbing this on
my forehead to see if it stops me from
sweating i bet it would
why not i mean i used to sweat so
bad profusely and i know this is not
something that women are supposed to
talk about
which is why i just did about it which
is that i used to have to
sew maxi pads into my shirts
on stage there were these things called
kleinert's pads i used to have to put in
my shirts
i almost got botox in my armpits i would
love to get botox on my whole body
please don't please i used to sell maxi
pads into my skin
please don't please don't do it i just
want you to know any of those things
and then i had a lot of breast cancer in
my family
and my gynecologist told me that
deodorants with aluminum in them
literally cause breast cancer i mean
that is just a true fact that is true
science
i'm a scientist sulfate's your baby
so i mean deodorant has been
truly until now until native
until natural deodorant has been
a war a weapon against women
i mean deodorant's been killing women
it's
it's so crazy and it also causes
alzheimer's
wow alzheimer's alzheimer's plural isn't
it
isn't that plural so native deodorant
this is
it this is the solution this is the fix
this is the truth that's your favorite
one right there
when you open it the lavender i'm
everything look there's a heart who
thought of that who thought of that
so benjamin penton's catchphrase who
thought of that
when you open up this deodorant this
just like makes me want to cry
it has an embossed heart you know why
has an embossed emblazoned heart
in the deodorant made with love just
what it says just to make your day made
with love
good packaging i feel it i think i could
start i could cry
shea butter coconut oil tapioca starch
it's vegan it's never tested
on animals bad ass switching to an
aluminum free deodorant doesn't mean you
have to sacrifice
odor protection native will keep you
smelling and feeling fresh
all day long it's a no brainer buy it
for your daughters buy it for your aunts
buy it for your mom
buy it for all the women in your life
it's risk-free to try
free shipping 30-day returns see why so
many people love native also the package
is this only for women
no oh then buy for everyone anyone can
use it oh sorry
sorry i'm sexist you know i'm sexist bad
for all the people because everyone can
use it they have
cucumber mint citrus and herb i mean and
look at that it goes on clear
look what i'm doing goes on clear no
white stuff yeah no weird nasty white
shit doesn't look like you've
snorted cocaine with your armpit when
you put it on it's also risk free to try
every product comes with free shipping
to the us
this interview 30 days returns and
exchanges see why so many people love
natives and check out why over
14 000 five-star reviews are about it
look at this
and it doesn't get all over your
freaking shirt it doesn't ruin your
clothes
that's true do what we did make the
switch to native today by going to
nativedo.com
whitney or use promo code whitney at
checkout and get 20 off
first order that's nativedeo.com
whitney or use promo code whitney at
checkout for 20 off your first
order let's talk about it so can you
manifest slash schedule ordain your
person because i do think you have to
have space available in your life
yeah i think timing's everything so i
like what you're doing
you sound like a psychopath but i agree
with you
right now i sound like it would not be
fair to someone else
to start dating them now because you
wouldn't be given the attention
and exactly that's exactly what you
can't show up at a hundred percent
where did you learn that um
why do you know that no man because i
know how i work because when i'm dating
someone and i have a lot of work going
on
normally i i will choose the girl and i
would leave my work aside
i know i do that because i've done it
before yeah but that's the wrong girl
the right girl won't let you do that but
i think it's not like she wasn't letting
me do that
sorry let me repeat that it's it's not
like she wasn't letting me do that i was
choosing to do that
i had nothing to do with it i know but
the right girl you wouldn't choose that
interesting yes yeah so you'll go i
wouldn't feel
i know you you know what i mean i don't
feel insecure i don't feel
uh um like
a sense of urgency i don't need to give
this thing up for you
i think um i'm not going to lose you
you don't have that energy i think when
it's right
like i just started dating someone that
i think is i think it's like
i think it's an experiment in the right
thing
because i'm i can delay gratification
with him
because i go i'm like on some new shit
that's like
well no the best thing i can do for us
is to finish my work and not see you
that because that's going to help me
avoid a future resentment
so that in two weeks i don't go well i
fucking gave up this for you
right i'm gonna continue working for you
i think um it was since it was his like
first real relationship
i think he was just excited about it
yeah no that that
so it was that people shit is real yeah
you have to do that that was an
important relationship to have right you
have to have had it it taught you a lot
i've learned a lot since then so now
like what
just a lot in the relationship like what
i what i should be doing what i should
do what i need to focus on more
like what's important in a relationship
biggest turn off in a girl
um clingy clingy yeah and
um unmotivated
clingy unmotivated that's really
important that you say that and let's
not rush through it because
i go back and forth because i'm like
i'm surprisingly traditional and i feel
like
in in terms of my radical acceptance of
human nature because i'm like
i don't want to show how motivated i am
to men because that's a masculine
quality
oh you think it's like competing against
sucks i
pretend that i'm like unemployed
to the guys i date they're like i'm like
running a podcast
doing a tour and they're like what are
you doing i'm like oh nothing just
laying around in bed doing nothing
like i am of the
um uh blueprint
that men don't want you to overachieve
men don't want you to have your own life
men kind of just want you to be i feel
like that's kind of changing yeah and
there's something sexy as fuck about it
though too
there is something sexy as fuck about it
you feel the same about
like about that now like you feel like
you still have to do that you can't hide
it anymore
like there's just no way with the
ubiquity of like you know social media
and such
but i definitely go out of my way or am
conscious of not the way that you talked
about the drake video which
we're coming back to um
i don't say what i'm doing
because i don't want it to come off that
i'm super super busy or ambitious
because
i was raised to believe that ambitious
was kind of ugly on a woman
that's so crazy because like when i met
my girlfriend mariah
she she works like six jobs like she
is just like a hustler love it and like
i found that
so attractive hot so hot i think it's
very attractive so dope
if you think she's working six jobs
she's working ten jobs like that's the
deal with women too if they have one job
they really have seven
you know and wait till she has kids
she'll have 12. right so like that to me
was like i was like oh wow
so dope just so driven she knew what she
wanted and just
yeah just really motivated and would do
whatever it took to succeed when did you
tell her you loved her
um it was probably
four or five months into wow what made
you do it
um just like the way the way
content i need to get an algorithm
i actually think i told her i loved her
before i even filmed a youtube video
with her
how did you know you loved her i've
dated like people in the past and i know
like what i felt about them which i
thought was right and what i felt with
her was completely different
which is can you put into words i'm
trying to figure out what this
generation i would never i would never
be able to do this right now
i know you're next um work on it i i
didn't realize the difference between
obviously like i was younger but like
lust and love mm-hmm
um and that was tricky i guess
eye-opening to me i
started seeing like oh i maybe i was
just attracted to this person and it
wasn't like a on a deeper
yeah emotional connection um
and yeah it was just different with her
are you the best version of yourself
with her
yeah what do you fight about
what's your last fight um i'm trying to
think we don't we don't fight a lot
we we don't really fight a lot um i
think
the last time we fought
i literally like you black out
if i i would like can you text her right
now and ask one's last time you thought
because she'll be like this morning
because i have this here guys i don't
think we're fine
she's talking to her mariah's talking to
her girlfriend right now like all we do
is fight and he's like we've never
fought before
like you just don't know that you were
in the fights maybe that's what's
happening very interesting to put it
that way
um okay so this is another way to
explain it we don't text her when was
our last fight i'm not joking
i would like to know her side of the
story and then
have you been in love um i thought i was
in love but
it was it was more lost so it was like
yeah it was just excitement
yeah in the moment convenient but uh
adrenaline
convenient yeah convenient is that is
that a bad word
it's not a bad word it's it's an
interesting word i've just never heard
it
in the context of love i mean
convenience is actually
i'm not saying that was when i love
somebody yeah like at the moment it just
was convenient that she was so hot
it was just convenient that my dick
always had come coming out of it it was
it was my first it was my first
relationship so yeah a lot of these
things were like i didn't know
yeah yeah but um
i've i've had like huge huge crushes
stop making
we were fighting about this on our
podcast i was like i need to hold my mic
as i i
need something to hold you you do have
like a very nervous energy
it's because of my hands i need
something to do with my hands you need
like a fidget spinner
yeah but is this a thing that you is
this
uh do you have a nervousness or what is
it is that you always have it i just
need something to do it's a nervous tic
are you on medication no you've never
been able to
you knew it's like i know something are
you on too much or too little adderall
i um now where were we because i fucking
friends it's okay
um i want to know do not put that lip
balm on your fucking mouth
you pick i gave him a very expensive lip
gloss to hold
so that he could calm his nerves terry
so how do we know each other we have a
little bit of a hit yeah
so i what was it i received a package
at my door when i lived on lori
in studio city and i received the
package and i looked at the package and
said whitney cummings
you got my mail what five years ago yeah
and this was shortly after this was i he
just told me this
right before the podcast and it all i i
didn't know who you guys were i still
kind of don't
but i also do and i feel like you're
kind of my sons
yeah like it's very weird i know you
very well but not at all
this is odd but i'm having flashbacks to
going like
oh this famous youtuber got my mail
i remember it and it was and can i tell
you something
that was back when i had resentment
towards famous youtubers
oh and she replied and that's why i was
jealous
i was jealous i was jealous you weren't
you're just like i don't want to talk to
a youtuber are you telling me how i feel
you need to fix this in the next two
months before you meet this girl okay
you can't tell women how they feel they
tell you how they feel
and you say i'm sorry you feel that way
okay i'll try life hack no but i mean i
i was
argent we are jealous of you our
generation's jealous of you do you feel
that
i didn't until i started seeing the tick
talkers
wow so so wow i know youtubers
wow used to feel this way about us when
we were starting on vine and i was like
they just hate us like
we're just trying to make videos and
have fun and i knew like a lot of
youtubers that just didn't like us
because they feel like we got it the
easy way
because it was like all we have to do is
make six second videos and i was like
oh well i'm still putting in the work
can we stop there yeah because
i would like to address that the easy
way
i still can't make an instagram reels
it's six seconds
that six seconds i can write a 120 page
feature script faster than i can make a
six second reels
i just don't it's harder for me to
distill
into six seconds i don't think it's good
enough i don't see myself as the product
i don't think i'm enough
just going like hey here's my wacky face
i don't have the self-esteem for it
i don't know why other people would like
it it makes me have a pit my stomach and
feel embarrassed and
ashamed um and also
i really want to deconstruct this
jealousy around um
youtubers because you guys are quickly
taking over the world
um in a lot of ways and
amanda cerny was on a couple weeks ago
and
she we met on something she comes to my
house and she's like let's do a video
and i'm like this is my first video with
a youtuber i don't know what
i i do tv shows i do movies yeah there's
a crew list there's 200 people there's a
union involved
there's craft services it costs millions
of dollars you have to get permission
from business people
in corporate in atlanta like new york
has to sign off
things have to be signed a lawyer like a
lawyer's involved it takes
four months to get a camera in front of
me
usually and uh disney's
legal has to look over your script first
the rigmarole that's exhausting okay
amanda comes over with her camera
she's in like mini shorts and a tube top
most beautiful girl i've ever seen puts
the camera on my
um uh uh easy words are hard for me
table and shoots something
the next day she sends it to me via
dropbox link
i can't even fucking open it and it's
like
goes out to 28 million people and
that is wild it is pretty crazy
it's uh and like how it started like how
did that start like why did it have to
go through so many approval process in
the beginning because it was a
sham it was a mara
it was a business you know and
everybody's just trying to get their own
piece of the pie trying to make we are
jealous
because we had to make get 200
pay 200 people to help us do the sound
and the mic and
this and the camera and this and the
lighting and the location and the
light and we had to get police officers
to block off streets so that we could
get the number of people
the permits and everything else and then
you guys
got to and i guess it's easier in some
way
but we used to have pre-production
production
post-production it would take about nine
months we had an editor we had a you
know
we had a post-production supervisor that
made sure
everything was moving smoothly i just
watched you guys
downstairs both of you writer star
actor editor sound guy best boy key grip
i mean every you do every job on the
call sheet so
yeah they they had it so easy but you're
also doing 200 jobs
zayn and i were talking about this the
other day i was like i was telling my
manager i was just like
why is it always so expected like we're
we're youtubers but like people
don't like we have to know filming
lighting
how to edit amanda blew my mind because
i've been i was tricked into believing
there are no female directors in
hollywood like i got
tricked into that bullshit like
propaganda of like holly okay
amanda was the editor the writer the
cinematographer the dp
and the director it's crazy you know but
so you guys just crushed us so for me
you guys are the new hollywood and doing
a movie or tv show at this point
is tantamount to 10 years ago
a hollywood movie star doing broadway
that's what you think they quit like
equivalently it's like yeah i'm gonna go
put on a play for 500 people a night
like that's
now like if i were to go do a tv show
that's like
what five ten years ago a big celebrity
doing broadway
right like i'm gonna go to this little
tiny i'm gonna go do tv i'm gonna take a
break
from media i'm gonna take a break from
being overexposed and go do a tv show
yeah and get some indie cred
interesting to think about flipped wild
what do you prefer
i don't um i don't think i can answer it
yet because i
haven't the last couple television shows
i did were so
um they were pilots were so harrowing
because of the personalities involved um
roseanne um i worked with the
really tricky personalities and that's
the other thing is that in order to
connect with fans viewers
we used to have to align with a bunch of
people we didn't know that quite frankly
we're mentally ill
and like this is this is like the
larry david seinfeld that was like the
lightning in a bottle
that was like oh they found the team
it's so rare that that happens right
yeah
you're just in an arranged marriage with
a bunch of people you've never met and
then you
try to all have the same vision for art
impossible impossible yeah
right so this is like it's just it's
distilled now
i feel like especially our friends we
all got really lucky with like just
understanding
the same we had the same humor we just
had laughed at the same things and we
we got it right within our within each
other at least yeah so what are you
how what's going to go on with the do
you think
like in two months when your schedule
frees up
what's going to happen i wish i never
said that are you going to go on bumble
are you going to go on hinge how's this
work
i'm i'm still on these like dating apps
i'm still like you know what at night
when i'm bored all like
he's trying to get a wet quick nut he's
not ready for a relationship
what makes what's a red flag and a woman
to you clingy is interesting
i don't think clickiness is a red flag
that's what's a red flag
uh like can a girl text you twice in a
row
uh yes because i would because i would
do that but that doesn't mean it's
okay but like i yeah no text twice that
would turn you off that wouldn't turn
you off that would not turn me off
so if you uh meet a girl mm-hmm
you're calling her are we calling
facetime
whoa straight to facebook our friend our
group only uses facetime sorry
our friend group only uses facetime like
it's just again like
i'm not good at texting like i i could
never text a girl that i'm talking to or
just me and have a conversation whether
to through text i could never do that
because
because i'm not good with i'm just not
good with texting i'm not like i'm not
flirtatious i'm not like
it's also it's it's an inferior way to
communicate words are imperfect words
uh mean different things to different
people the punctuation like if someone
says
like um talk to you soon period i'm like
why are you mad
yeah it's a rorschach test yes
words are a flawed uh method of
communication
i was gonna say he used to have me fight
with his girlfriend because he's like i
don't know how to write this like can
you just like write this for me say say
something like this and i'll just be
like
because i would have to i always have to
talk on the phone but like there's times
where we wouldn't talk on the phone it
was only through text because it was
like it got serious
so it was like a text fight and i'm not
good at texting i don't know how to
do voicemail that's helped me i don't
even think there are voice memos
at the time i think i think using
texting was to avoid that type of
conversation like yeah verbally i would
like to solve some of your problems
okay because i feel like you guys are
pretty much set in your life
right um i don't like mentally
yeah like you're no not in the sun i'm
definitely not
so what can i help you with
um if you're a mother i do i do
you have a very warm welcoming presence
right like when i walked in i was like a
little nervous watch this because like
i've never really done um a guest
podcast like this
oh really um and i was just are you
above this no no we
just are you stooping i just don't think
we're comfortable doing other people's
that's why
why i i don't know i
it's like not the home court advantage
kind of and why would you yes
i never really got asked there was like
a couple little things but it wasn't
like
somebody else who who runs like a big
successful podcast
um and also i was just like really
curious to see like
what you're set and like the way you
like i just wanted to learn like how you
run your show here
um so i was just kind of like a little
so you're doing research right now
yeah a little bit so everything you do
you're
thinking in terms of your business yeah
love it unapologetic
pretty much fantastic
like that's why i was like how long do
you like plan these out like each guest
like yeah
turnaround rate yeah interesting yeah
like to me i wasn't thinking about any
of that
to me it was like oh i wonder how she is
as a person i wonder if she's nice or is
she like straight
straight what do you think what did you
think i would love to hear what do you
what did you think i was going to be
versus what i am um
i'm fascinated by what we project on to
people yeah because i projected onto you
guys
quite a bit yeah i used to be jealous of
you
i when when you found my mail i was
looking at this motherfucker oh this
like yeah i don't have that now anymore
and now you're this like warm um
you know you're like the twins from the
shining in the hallway
just i need to play with us or whatever
it was my two broken boys
i'm gonna be honest with you because of
the little conversation we had through
twitter dms
when you said uh yeah just leave it
leave it somewhere i'm gonna have my
assistant pick it up so
i've always remembered that last year
because i would never do that to
somebody i was dming
like be like oh just drop it off i'll
have myself so you said i i got your
mail and i wrote back i'm gonna have my
assistant pick it up it was something it
was something very
straight to the point of time big time
so in my head was like oh
definitely because i'm a youtuber that's
what i caught so and you felt like she
doesn't respect me
100 wow so you know and and
now look i was intimidated by you
i was triggered by you you were
triggered by us well i'm saying not
us wait no because because we're
youtubers
you and your inner child no but it i i
was jealous of you
i felt like your existence big-timed me
and then you felt like i was big-timing
you yeah
wild and so i didn't know how to like i
don't know how it would be so when i got
in
i was sitting on the floor on the laptop
and i heard you go where is he
let me say hi i was like okay it's
getting better and then you thought i
was gonna be like a bitch like uh
i don't know i thought like i didn't
know if you were gonna because some
people are just kind of like all right
we're not gonna meet until we go to the
podcast room
yeah that's interesting yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was curious about how that would
go down too like if we were gonna hang
for a second
um like before or if it was just gonna
be like all right let's do it like let's
record
even the the down time i'm always split
on that and i try to just trust my gut
and see
um i wanted to see i'm really glad that
it happened the way it did because i
really
i'm glad i saw you guy they ca they show
up in my house
and they're in on that broke through the
front door
uninvited in their um uh
lamborghinis and uh which didn't trigger
me
which was so interesting like i was like
oh these motherfuckers i was
i was i normally would you didn't see
our cars before you saw us because i was
driving up and i was like
i love that you have shame around and
see i i
love that you have shame you should
that's the reason
that's a healthy reaction yeah i was
hoping to god he wasn't driving up in
his lamborghini and i saw it i was like
fuck
because you guys are like the opposite
of dan bilzerian you're like
insecure you're like
insecure dan bilzerians that's really
funny we like everything that's
expensive
wow wild that was that's the only car i
had so i was like fuck i have to drive
in the car i was like
please bring your truck it reminds me
like uh a while ago when i started like
getting a little bit of money i thought
i was like okay i'm doing well i can i
can be with the big dogs and i bought
a fucking gucci jacket i don't know why
i was just like
did it work absolutely not i fucking
hate it did it fix that swimming camp
trauma never wore it i've never worn a
day in our life
i feel so embarrassed like it's so
embarrassing if i put it on it went to
go out i would be
it's just not who i am and i felt so
weird and now it just sits in my closet
and i look at it and i'm just like
what are you doing it's just such a what
is that you should do a giveaway you
should give it away
that would be cool actually do a
giveaway for that you get a little bit
of money in your account and you just
think you can
i know i started like when i first i did
an
impression of what i thought i was
supposed to be doing like i saw pretty
woman and this is what i'm supposed to
be doing and then i was like oh that
just made me feel worse
i have such bad um i don't buy new stuff
because i just feel
um it makes me feel gross like i just i
don't i don't like it
i'm just the only time spending money
feels good is when it's on like animal
surgeries or
foster dogs or abused elephants and
stuff that's the only
that to me is like my birken bag like
how maybe some people feel about a
bergen bag
you know because i just yeah um it makes
me feel
stupid it makes me feel like i'm bad at
math
yeah um that's another one i love how
you do that
i have like a nasty a really nasty
relationship with money
it can really make me feel gross real
fast yeah i've definitely been there
before a couple times in my life
so what's going on with you guys when
you go on a date like has
has this me too reckoning made you
afraid that you're going to be accused
of
assault all the time um i'm going to be
completely honest
it has not like assault but yeah i am a
fr i don't like
i don't dm girls on my instagram smart
i don't i like it's i don't know and i'm
not scared i'm not saying i'm like
no deep in secrets by the way i i was
dating a guy who was
30 um a couple months ago and we when we
hooked it up he's like can i kiss you
can i
it was like it was everything was a
question and everything
he would say like can you call me i
can't put this in text like when i would
try to do sexy texts like it was
you know it was fascinating like there's
the like there's dm's i'll get were like
so everything you put in you assume can
be screen grabbed exactly
like girl like there'll be girls that
will send videos or pictures of
themselves naked
and they'll be like verified people
okay and to me 100 i'm just like oh this
is a trap
boom so i finished jerking off the trash
and put it straight into the fucking
trash can it's because i don't i don't
know i just like
yeah i've seen way too many people just
like i don't think this isn't a reaction
i don't think that's an over
correction i mean that's smart and i'm
traditional too i love meeting people in
person
like i love meeting girls like at a bar
i'm like
little tipsy i turn around i see a girl
that like i'm really like i find
very attractive and i want to go up to
her and like that's how i like to do it
yeah yeah
okay i've been with mine for three years
mm-hmm so i haven't
been in the dating system he's on the
side so what's going on with that what's
up with the
are you gonna get married um down the
road yeah
what's your like what's this
generation's take on marriage
scary yeah why i want to wait till like
40.
uh-huh why because i like
marriage to me is not like what it what
it started out as
yeah i i don't know that is a business
shield
i don't think marriage is i think it
should be something where it's not like
but you believe in monogamy not marriage
do you believe in monogamy what monogamy
is when you do
i don't yeah i'm really bad with my
fucking vocabulary words too
that's another problem of mine monogamy
is here let's guess let's do this
guys their twenties don't even know what
the word monogamy means
can i guess what it means yeah yeah yeah
monogamy is
when a person can date multiple people
at the same time
married sorry married with uh
this is fucked up i hate this
to be fair she has been throwing out a
lot of big words this whole time and
sometimes i'm trying to like use context
clues i was tripping you every time
she was saying i was just like he's
texting me under the table like
yo what did that mean we avoid big words
any chance we get on our fucking show
because we can't
we just can't do it we don't know i
dropped out baby after two years
monogamy
you want me
that's so funny monogamy is when you
only sleep with one person
oh a complete opposite of what you're
literally opposite of what you said yeah
fuck
oh my god polygamy is when you fuck with
more than one people
oh my god so do you believe in monogamy
um
uh that's a no i mean now yes yes yes no
no like when you
you're with one person you stay with one
person until you break yeah yes yeah
yeah
yeah 100 yeah i
[Laughter]
i'm with a girl i'm with you i will
never ever even
take a glance at it because to me i'm
trying to understand if like
because what i'm learning from you guys
like you guys are giving me
a lot of like hope for the future
because
you guys are good it's very nice you're
the
template for boys they look up to you
and they're going to do what you do
because you guys are their heroes and
you're cool
and to me when
when i was growing up masculinity
a tough guy an awesome guy fucked lots
of chicks and
cheated like that was glorified and you
guys are
glorifying not on purpose just
inherently
um integrity
and loyalty and it's to me the
it's the opposite of toxic masculinity
and it's just fucking awesome
like this is what's going to fix
everything it's just being a human
you're feminist yes kind of in a way
yeah
kind of in a way no i'm saying like
you're a feminist off of yeah
you're a feminist do you disagree no i i
cool i i mean i've never been like i'm a
feminist like labeling myself like but i
do you think if you and i do the same
job we should make the same amount of
money
yes do you think if you and him are
getting the same amount of attention and
views and everything yeah of course yeah
you're a feminist
but because you i don't know if you guys
know it but you're feminine you see to
me
i don't even think a term is necessary
that's right i agree
the word feminist has been so just like
um
polluted by like bullshit nonsense it's
turned into like
women should be equal they should be
superior frankly it's turned into this
like crazy like entitlement nonsense
thing
but i find that pretty fascinating
i just see everybody as equal like same
same line so
we're kind of breaking the fourth wall
here but the way that this works
is they send sponsors will send us
products
we will try them if we believe in them
if we like them if we think that they
are not full of shit capitalist
conspiracies
and something that feels organic and
we're not total con artists for
supporting
and working with we talk about them
olipop is a beverage that my
dear friend esther was drinking i asked
her to send me some
that's helps that's that's how obsessed
with it i was she sent me some
then i messaged our ad salesperson and
said can olliepop be a sponsor
it's a healthy alternative i asked that
i asked them to sponsor
us they sent us the product
we drank it all in one day we didn't
drink
we drank all of it truly in one day
secondly we drink two cases
we drank two cases of it in one day i
thought esther had sent it to us
it's actually olipop sent it to us we
drank all of the product and have none
of it
but it's really good isn't that kind of
the best endorsement of it
i mean i think so because listen it's
not
only just a good healthy alternative to
soda but why don't you why are you so
insistent on reading this
it has probiotics and plant fibers and
botanicals because i think people should
know what they're buying well here's the
that's a good point you're in tomorrow
i'm into the emotion side of this you're
into the marketing side
sometimes saying something okay so
here's esther here's esther here she
comes
okay esther is facetiming us back so
did you so esther's who introduced us to
lollipop
that's crazy you're the one that made
this
happen i don't know how
well the orange squeeze is my what's
your favorite flavor because you posted
you posted yourself on instagram
drinking the orange squeeze and i was
like i need to get that because it'll
make me seem young
okay well my so for me it's
vintage cola yeah the root beer oh
i like cherry vanilla beer is exactly
root beer
the cherry vanilla that's my favorite
but they put probiotics in it
yeah who thought of that fiber what
genius
psychopathic genius thought to just
solve all my problems with one soda i
know it tastes so good too
but it does it it like checks every box
90 of americans consume more than the
usda's daily recommended added sugar
intake
sweetened beverages like sodas are the
leading source of added sugars in the
american diet
only pop is lower in sugar you can't do
that
you can't have those drinks anymore like
those drinks are cancelled you have to
have a drink
that's less sugar but that's gonna make
you feel like you're getting
your sweet fizziness they solved it they
fixed it those days are over this has
two to five grams of sugar from natural
sources
thank you no added sugar no added sugar
vintage cola has two grams of sugar
as compared to regular coca-cola which
has 39 grams of sugar
drag them drag them
snatch their wig and it's by the way
whitney whenever you get the variety
pack at your house it's so perfect
because we like the different flavors
so we're actually a really good match
yeah no it's kind of true it's very
symbiotic all their products our
probiotics are symbiotic
all their products are also non-gmo
vegan paleo
and keto friendly with less than eight
grams of net carbs magicians
make this company what is that how do
that's amazing it's just water
they're so confident that you love their
product they offer 100 money back
guarantee
if you're like a complete sociopath
um they're delicious and and benton's
gonna read the rest and i'm gonna show
you
uh esther we've worked out an exclusive
deal
for the good for you podcast listeners
receive 20 off plus free shipping on
their best
selling variety pack this is a great way
to try all of their delicious flavors
go to drink lollipop dot com slash
whitney or use code whitney at checkout
to claim this deal
that's d-r-i-n-k-o
dot com slash whitney this discount is
only valid for their variety pack
lollipop can also be found in over 3000
stores across the country including
whole foods
sprouts kroger shout out to the kroger
kingdom's and irawan
on kroger
kroger lollipop what's up my two
favorite things
the best new soda best new soda and
send me more because we drank it all
honey
i have to be honest i'm very excited
that we
have honey working with us but i'm
intimidated because bill burr does ads
about honey
and he nails them he's always very good
he's just the way he says it just it
always makes me think about bill burr
honey honey
we have to make this as good as bill
burr's explanation of honey well i don't
know if we can't follow that now
so when i was a kid we would go to the
grocers
we'd go down to the store we'd go down
to the grocery
and the food line or the kroger or the
piggly wiggly and
my aunt would have a bag of coupons i
love that you could go to brand name
stores like that
i went to a cb you know what that is
that's right no one does because we
owned
somebody owned it it was a random store
this summer's backyard yeah it was just
a half a gas station
and we'd go check out and the groceries
would be like 150
my aunt would pull out her ziploc bag
full of coupons
and then just put pulling them out
pulling them out pulling them out
getting paper cuts from all the coupons
they're all crumpled up and musty
nasty and you guys would leave with
eight tube the toothpaste
and it would be like down to twelve
dollars
like the coupon game was so strong the
cool thing about honey though is that
you can get
on things you want but honey is now's
version of
super saving coupons right yeah honey
you go on to
wow what's happening sorry chaos you go
on to
basically you download honey on your
computer if you have a computer it
should have honey on it just
it's two clicks like it's not like a
regular wall it's not like getting hbo
maps it's like an app
you download the app honey on your
computer go to
good for you then when you're checking
out
on one of its over 30 000 supported
sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupons it will search the
internet for
any coupon that may work if one works
it'll apply it for you if there are none
it will say
better luck next genius honey has 17
million members don't be the idiot
that's not on honey now you're just
losing money
money it might that's why rhymes with
money
money money money get that money honey
that's what it is people over two
billion dollars
so this is really just it's not optional
like you have this is free
this is a form of self-care honey is a
form of self-care
it's simple if you don't have honey you
hate yourself okay
i truly i mean it's true it's you hate
money it's simple
why would you why wouldn't you have it
give me one reason why you wouldn't have
honey
i mean i have honey you haven't had it
for a long time i know what i'm saying
who wouldn't have it if you don't have
honey
you're just you hate yourself it's
simple getting honey is a positive
investment in your future self i've now
said it's simple eight times
i know but i'm just i i'm i i'm feeling
a little bit of
shock that it's only 17 million members
okay
guys guys it's simple it's simple
if you have a computer honey should be
on it it's my billboard impression
and works with whatever browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
good for you two clicks that's join
honey dot com slash good for you
honey game change it's a game changer
supported by over 30 000
honey honey honey
i was going to say i got my my text back
by the way and what is it
your girl texted you back what was your
last fight with mariah
i don't even know if i can read it you
can you can read it
um content comments for podcasting
uh all the ads are in mariah
oh boy this is this is he texted her
asking what their last fight was
he says they never fight i'm gonna read
the text
i only remember me being on your ass
about cocaine
[Music]
i didn't read that part
oh but the hats have been a long ass
time ago did you do cocaine
a long time ago it was bad you did
cocaine a lot yeah
oh my zayn don't answer
me let me tell you something i it's so
interesting
you said that because gosh it's it
really is i love it
oh my god oh my god i love this
everything
that we suggest in just as a joke
everything we accuse other people love
we do i was in the bathroom earlier i
have allergies because of the work being
done in my home
and i said i was like i was like i'm
sniffling and he goes cocaine and i was
like that's so weird that that's where
his mind went well
no it was because you came out and you
were like oh sorry uh allergies
like and it was like you were like
trying to like somebody's impression of
me
someone called lauren michael let's send
that tape in
literally nailed me um but yeah so i
thought like you were coming out being
like don't think like it was that
but that was your projection onto me
because that's
just making a joke yeah um yeah i know
but it was a joke but it came from
you having done that before correct wild
and this is okay heath it's okay that
you feel like this oh don't don't sit me
down
that's so what because i i remember
going that's so weird that he went to
cocaine
like i haven't thought about cocaine in
so long
it's also immature too you know
interesting
so when did you stop doing cocaine um
a few years ago did you how did you stop
um just called turkey
wow that's unusual
i was waiting until you guys have paused
don't wait until you pause
off cooking do you not like to talk
about it um i just know my parents are
gonna be watching this episode
super excited to see me connecting with
you and this is just gonna be like
but there is nothing to be afraid of
it's
cooler no then then broadcasting to the
world
yeah i stopped doing this destructive
thing right
it didn't work like what you're doing is
heroic
thank you um and i'll like i won't touch
it
there's nothing harder as someone that
there is a meme the other day that
someone sent me that was just
it said nobody you know nobody blank
all right and then it just said whitney
i identify as an addict
because i say that so much so i identify
as an addict
uh there's nothing harder i have
i mean i i don't talk about it too much
publicly but i have family members that
are literally
homeless drug addicts there's nothing
harder than stopping a drug the fact
that you stopped that means you have
something that we call the warrior
spirit
okay i'm not gonna leave i'm not gonna
leave him hanging here because just in
case you don't cut this out
i had a problem with drugstore when i
was in florida well that's actually i
mean
i said oh that goes to that by the way i
knew you guys had drug problems because
you told me you were from florida
i know these type of people i'm not
letting him i'm not gonna let him stay
here and
run through that by himself i had a
problem too
wow and how did he stop let me have the
spotlight
oh my
[Laughter]
oh fuck that's too funny and so
but i love this i love seeing successful
people that are not on drugs
yeah and talking about that they were
and they used that as an anesthetic
what were you on
oh my god are you guys doing tick tock
challenges are we on drugs right now
i think so has become this has become
serious uh this is like a serious
shit this is a serious drug it's a
serious drug drug
i hope i don't like lose everything in
my life because
i think i think you're about to gain a
lot more okay so
back in florida you're about to gain my
respect i don't think so
don't speak too so in florida um a very
popular drug in florida but we would
take like
meth methadone methadone oxy uh
cotton uh uh
um fentanyl it's like synthetic heroin
you take the pill you put on a phone no
i know it died no she got it right you
know i have family in florida oh
that went to rehab like i we've met
yeah i think i think oxycontin is the
word for it because in florida you can
get
in the well my experience with the
person
was on um uh
oxycontin which she was able to get from
a public
like free clinic or something like in
florida there's some law where you can
procure
that and you can get method there are
methadone clinics yeah and there was
there are doctors selling it to these
kids like they yeah
this person went to rehab and a lot of
times people go to rehab
and when they get out it gets worse for
them
because rehab if you're going to relapse
rehab is basically a giant advertisement
for all the amazing drugs you haven't
tried yet so you're sitting around with
a bunch of drug addicts and you're like
dude i gave up my baby for a zany bar
and then the addict gets out and goes i
need a zany bar i heard about that shit
in rehab
that's so bad and things get even worse
and then that's when the heroin
and heroin is almost always what um
addicts that go into rehab come out
doing
come out doing because they hear about
in rehab wow
thank god we didn't go to heroin we beat
this beat the system
beat the algorithm we picked up a phone
and
started filming ourselves and stuff
right right so do you think that because
i think we're all addicted to some it's
my personal theory it's not a fact
that's not true we're all addicted to
something
um and in terms of like the thing that
anesthetizes us that gives us the sort
of neurochemical
equilibrium that makes us be able to not
be restless irritable and discontent
yeah so i very much think that my
current drug is
work you know do you think you have kind
of
um not sublimated it but
transmuted that into this
like if you had to stop working tomorrow
for whatever reason
you know what i mean how would you does
this soothe you
doing all this uh no i feel i i
feel like i want to work more and no i
didn't put like it doesn't feel like an
obligation it doesn't feel like an
obligation i honestly i wish
work was more of an obligation because i
feel like i'm not working a lot
i feel like i'm doing the bare minimum
right now in it you but but i think but
that is all that is
could be dysmorphic think i mean you
came to my house
and you guys were uploading a video
while you were waiting to do this in the
20-minute window
yeah how many hours a day do you work
maybe like we're
there's not much going on right now
because we only have our podcasts so
it's it's hard to
say like what work is for us like yes
there's so much that goes into our work
because you're
always together you're thinking about it
you're always brainstorming you're it's
like
you're in the you're the championship
like to me labor are you the truman show
it's basically your life is the truman
show have you seen that
it kind of feels like it sometimes it is
yeah yeah every one
of you is your own truman show that's a
we're all just extras in your movie yeah
i've thought about that like last night
um my girlfriend was editing the podcast
that we were just uploading and
something went wrong with our cameras
so we couldn't sync the audio with the
video because the cameras weren't
recording audio
so she started it at seven o'clock at
night and i was with her helping her
trying to get these clips to match up
and we didn't get the video synced until
6 30 in the morning before she even
started editing it
so it was like that what was that um
deadline was that a self-imposed
deadline
yeah just just to get it up for today
but so why do you impose that deadline
that could be your drug it could be
adrenaline
addicted to the gotta put it up because
you didn't have to do that
you could have pushed it a day because i
feel like we're like very lazy for the
first
like few episodes we would upload kind
of whenever we wanted that day we'd
upload late and we
we weren't like that strict with
ourselves but they got to a point where
we felt like okay
we need to like run it like a show like
because i started thinking about
imagine like i wanted to watch game of
thrones i know what comes on it
eight o'clock at night and it's not
there and it's supposed to be that
like i'm always like ready for it at
that time and they were just like oh
well we just didn't finish it on time
it's just gonna be tomorrow
and you just start losing the trust of
viewers interesting
people are you have to be consistent
they're getting well
uh you are their drug
and you have to be consistent or they'll
just get addicted to someone else
right who is consistent makes sense
that's fascinating so you really have to
unders you have a very deep
understanding of human nature because of
what you do
and i don't know if that's chicken or
egg
egg eat
he goes no no i'm not hungry
i'm good
does me look at her like all these
equations are on my head like
what is witness
so what's gonna so i wanna know more
about how you guys
view women this is fascinating and
like so healing to me um this is all i
ever wanted
like this doesn't make me cry i'm here
to hear zayn and i talk about
is to hear me to see the next generation
of men
respect women this is like what i've my
whole
purpose in life that i've been yelling
into a microphone at people
to get men to want
a woman to have an orgasm when they fuck
them
that did not go where i thought it was
going i
i like this is all i've ever wanted and
it's right in front of me
cool i'm really going to have this
battery life you just want like just our
overall or do you want to ask like a
specific
um like when you fuck girls you want
them to have orgasms
right
to me that sounds weird because i don't
know anybody who is like
i don't want them to
so yeah but that doesn't mean you know
how to do it do you know what i mean
okay so what's going so how did
so how much porn did you guys watch
growing up yes
um everything growing up for me was
parental locked
mm-hmm so i couldn't because i was
worried
that your generation uh had a
very fucked up relationship with sex and
women because of the porn you watched
that's the like
prevailing theory i think it's the
generation below us yeah
interesting they're the ones who are
getting so exposed to everything so
early
got it and like kids with smartphones
like did you guys pay for porn at any
point
no i've always known porn was a complete
show
like it was completely you're able to go
i know what this is
i'm jerking off to this i know this is
not reality yeah i know a girl does not
expect
me to do that did you see a naked woman
before you saw porn
yes yes interesting okay okay because
they're seeing porn before they see
naked women right
and like and it might be a letdown
frankly at the time like i didn't we
didn't have smartphones at the age we
would be like and when did you guys
start having sex
younger or older uh i think i was seven
17 18 wow see that's late and the age of
guys losing their virginity is going up
yeah wild mild so you're fucking nerds
very much totally yeah i was like i was
a thespian
i had no like i barely had friends when
you have sex with girls do you
feel like you have to fuck like you see
in porn
no you don't think about porn why you're
having sex no
no are you choking women no
i'm not choking well unless they're like
choking it depends on them they're like
do you get a lot of that yeah i that's i
mean sometimes i'm just like
uh like how hard do you go
do you want to like make them want to be
choked or is it like something
if a woman says choke me what do you do
how tiny is this girl
how old are the girls
no no it's i'm just answering your
questions what happens
um i mean it's probably maybe a couple
times
choke me choke me it's become such a
it's become such a like a tick tock
thing too
it's like this whole young generation is
like it's all like choke me daddy and
like it's just like
it's it's really uncomfortable because
some of these kids are so young talking
about this stuff and like it's
wild it's it's so bizarre um
yeah you can't do choke me daddy when
you live with your dad yeah
like if you're too young to be doing
that i'm curious and if you were to if
you were to have a kid right now
they are seven six or seven years old
would you let them have a phone and be
on like no the internet and tick tock
and all of that right
now um just curious because i know that
i would
yeah i would have to do some recon on it
like i i don't
i don't think that it's doing as much
damage as we think it's doing
um because
and because you want a child to be
prepared for what reality will be like
you don't want them to be a luddite so
that they're not able
you know um and i also think that
every generation swings the opposite way
that is the one previous
do you know what i mean so it's like
younger kids now think instagram is lame
because their parents do it
don't i mean like younger kids don't
smoke weed now because
their parents smoke weed weed's not cool
because
every generation wants to do the
opposite of what their parents did and
there's actually a term for it um that i
don't
know uh i'll i'll probably think of it
or maybe i could just
uh if only there was a machine where i
could find out the word right away
um but uh it's the biological basis for
it
is that offspring wants to differentiate
themselves from their
parents from predators you know because
you know so
um offspring always wants to look
different
than their parents right so um
if my parents are smoking weed i don't
want to smoke weed if my parents
are on social media i don't want to be
on social media so my guess is this next
generation isn't going to think it's
cool
we'll see yeah unless we have the neural
link and all that shit
yeah what's your thoughts on that um i
was just
writing some jokes about it actually and
i was like
um you just had these already planned
out so you had to like throw neural link
in because you wanted to tell these
jokes so anyway
perfect segue to my next special i would
actually love to hear some of you
no i actually was i was just working on
the plane
about neuralink about how um
all is going to be revealed basically
and we're going to find out how sexist
everyone is and when we have neuralink
you can like pass a thought right like
if if i i i
lex was on the podcast the other day and
we were supposed to talk about it and we
got
so distracted by our chemistry that we
didn't get to it but um
i was like where all will be revealed it
will be revealed that i'm a complete
hypocrite because like when i'm sitting
on a plane and a female pilot comes on i
go
uh-oh we all think that
we all think that but then i don't think
we've ever seen one huh i don't think
i've ever seen
really yeah yeah not a pilot no i have
not seen a friend a female pilot when a
female pilot comes on the point i go
uh oh which is what like amelia earhart
that didn't end so well do you know what
i mean oh you see i don't even think
about emilia
but that's something if we're
broadcasting our thoughts you're gonna
broadcast my entire
gymnastics i go through but then i end
up on top because then i have to argue
with myself and i go
no if there's a female pilot on this
plane she had to work twice as hard
right to get half as far so she's
probably twice as good and you're twice
as safe
but the whole reason we're able to
function in society is my first
super sexist racist disgusting
phobic nasty thought i was able to keep
inside
right so and just knowing that it's just
a thought
it's just a thought and it's not it's
not i didn't do anything wrong
it's just a thought it's not my fault
it's oops
for me it's it's young people behind a
plane
behind pilots i'm i am so wildly ageist
and i am working on it very ageless i'm
so ageist and it's
interesting because um it's so
opposite like we have this thing that's
like i mean obviously older people have
more like
wisdom obviously in a lot of ways but
you guys have access
to so much more now that we should kind
of
have more respect for younger people why
do we
i think it's just like knowing that yeah
that they have the experience like if i
saw somebody who looked
you know 22 years old flying a 747
i'd be like you haven't been doing this
long enough although
the best vet is the youngest
because they know the newest technology
and all the newest stuff that is
interesting yeah
so to me if i if my dog is dying and i
go into a vet and an old guy comes out
fuck that i want the youngest person in
there that has the newest technology
and is like the quickest and has the
most recent science yeah because older
people stick to traditions they like
they
they only stick to they're not updating
their software yeah
how do i know you've updated your
software it's like yeah like are we on
safari which one
are we on it's crazy watching fast food
places still having the
slow ass systems that are like taking
forever
and it's still like the black and the
green screen it's like how
how what just like like you know how
like
there's there's such faster technology
now where you can replace everything
that like in all retail stores and fast
food places you can replace everything
to make it a lot faster
but still you see these giant black
boxes
where the letters are still green and
black wait i i'm
you're totally lost sorry i was going
off of this
like um charlie brown like i just hear
like younger how younger people
are finding better and newer
technologies like
so i went to the route of just like the
like the old like
when you see something archaic yeah you
know i mean it's like it's
it's like the most recent when you go
and see that there's a new technology
and then you've been doing it the old
way
like i was working on this joke about
going to um the doctor
for uh to get a kova test and they asked
to take my temperature and i like pulled
my pants down it's like
right ma'am like put your asshole away
like we used to just put thermometers in
our butts
do you know what i mean yeah like it's
like i always find out what new
technology there is when i go to the
doctor
like we used to get naked at the doctor
oh my god i have a really funny story
yeah i've been naked once at the doctor
you don't do that anymore no that's not
oh so also there's a chaperone now
i went i went to a doctor when i was
younger you were molested
let's talk about it yeah okay what's
your health
insurance plan what's the youtube
insurance
yeah i went to this doctor one time when
i was younger and i didn't know like i
always just thought you had to like do
that to bend over and like
show your ass like i don't know why wait
what
did you you saw it like on the
coppertone bottle i don't know what it
was
i don't know if i this is so bizarre
um but the guy he was just like all
right we got to do
i think i was getting like uh a physical
where they had to like
squeeze your balls whatever make you
cough yeah okay the prostate exam is
that what that is
no the like it was like it was just a
normal physical i thought no hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
in a physical do you pull your dick out
yes yeah
all those days i okay so the thing was
like he told me to
he told me to get this at a catholic
church no
no this was at like a child pediatrician
office
i pulled my pants down and turned around
yeah
that probably hit me as soon as i
thought it was
it thought it was in florida okay
all right joe you don't pull your oh my
god i
turned crazy i pulled my pants down and
turned around and he just stood there
and he was like
all right great turn around now okay
wait wait wait wait wait i just wasn't
supposed to do that
my doctor was also like he watched me
bend over he's like
great now turn around so so you so how
old were you
i think i was probably like 12
13. i was wrong but you just turned you
spread your butt cheeks
i didn't i didn't spread them but i
turned around and kind of like
bent over i don't know what i was
thinking it was supposed to be i thought
i don't know but i did feel you should
have farted in his face
he's just like great now you can stand
up and turn around
okay now i have to go to jail
now i'm on megan's law thank you so much
mine was like he like so he pulled my
pants all the way down wait what
he my panties how old are you no no how
old were you
i was probably like around like 10 11
like probably
around the same age my pants were all
like to my ankles okay
and like his head was like right there
and he was just like checking it but he
you know he didn't do anything other
than that but now that i'm knowing that
this is not how
that's supposed to be that's not a
protocol i i
don't i've i got molested the
old-fashioned way
uh not at the doctor's office but this
doesn't sound right
dave thumbs up or thumbs down do
do finish it right now do you show dicks
at
in physicals they'll let us
like 12 or 13. yeah back when molesting
boys was okay
yeah i mean oh man now it does sound
like it was like very natural okay
i don't think this any of this was this
was untoward
yeah that that doesn't matter right yeah
i i do
think so many of you guys were molested
and nobody talks about it or even knows
it like
now that i'm thinking about it i don't
think so i don't think you know i think
i think we spend so much time talking
about sexual abuse and assault
of girls because we even though it's
incredibly delayed most of the time in
our ability to talk about it and put it
together
like we eventually are able to talk
about it i feel like
the same shit happens to men and they
never are
evil able to talk about it if they do
talk about their pussies
right toxic masculinity damn it no i'm
saying and
going right back if you were like if a
guy admits he was molested like that
means you were molested so many so
you know that means so much more
happened i feel like you guys would only
admit a tiny percentage of what actually
happened
hide it covered up baby so what are we
going to go back to florida and get this
shit right
i want to go see that doctor let's call
ronan farrow right now he was on the
podcast this year
um what's going on uh with women
are they shaving their pubes have you
ever seen pubes in person
um i think they they're they're yeah
they're pretty on it now
i guess on it
are you plugging joe rogan's vitamins
what's happening
they um i guess they do it yeah oh
is this how is is this how it's going to
be what i didn't mean to say it like
that
yeah they're fucking honest what does
[Laughter]
what do you prefer i don't i normally
don't care
really i think this is
i just think it's important because i
feel like women only talk
to women about this kind of stuff and we
forgot to talk to you guys and just ask
what you actually want instead of us
guessing all the time so i like to just
ask communication yeah i'm like whatever
makes you feel comfortable that's what i
am about okay if i if it was good
honestly i'm being dead good answer come
on
this media trainer did a great job so
what do you prefer i would prefer yeah
not ball i mean
like landing strip just uh heart
just groomed the lamborghini logo right
exactly
just that little shield the bermuda
triangle
the buckwheat and girls just have anal
sex now no problem
i don't i don't think so no i think i
think it's all talk everybody's just
like
yeah it is all the time it is and it's
just like
what not one girl that i've been with
was like i wanted in my ass
can can you eat my eyes not one girl
it's all smoke and mirrors isn't it yeah
yeah because they're watching all this
goddamn porn and it's like it's porn and
it's music there all anyone talks about
is eating ass i'm like where is it
where where do you go
show me the essay do girls somebody else
do girls even like putting things up
their butt
uh i think anal sex i think
some women enjoy anal sex if they know
it's
happening we need a heads up accidental
we needs a heads up i'm gonna order a
very different thing for dinner
and i don't mean to be i'm not trying to
be gross i just mean like you actually
need a heads up
um and you have to have like lube ready
you know like you just have to know you
know what i mean i think it can be
stupid it's got to be premeditated yes i
think it'd be like
super dope you can't just feel like a
mom huh
the birds and the bees talk but
yeah there's no there's no and there's
also this thing where i feel like guys
now
they just they treat our bodies like
like whack-a-mole they think every hole
has to be filled
during sex there's like a finger in the
bud and then they're making out with you
and then they're fucking you and it's
just like
you don't have to fight trying to mimic
what they've seen right basically yeah
like not all the holes have like i don't
know what guys think they're doing when
they put their fingers in our box
she's just like what the fuck is going
on like i just i
ca there's no air going out of my body
in any way like i just like i'm just
it's just like so i i don't know
i don't know i don't know what guys
think that is i don't know what do you
think you're doing when you
put your fingers in our body i think
it's people just not knowing what to do
so they're just
panicked just crying shit they're
watching a lot of porn they think that's
what they need to do
yeah that's what you're saying yeah they
have their head at their ass yeah
uh wild but guys aren't eating ass now
guys are like
i'm not in i'm personally not i'd rather
not i don't want a dingleberry in my
in my mouth just like a little you know
what i mean yeah and it's like what are
you gonna do say
ill once you catch something that's your
fucking fault you put your ass next to
that
like it's not her fault
i'd rather not if you get some peanut
butter on your left you got
that that's that's whole and there's no
going back from that you're just like
i'd rather not i would not make a girl
eat my butthole like
you're not into ass eating no not really
i'm not
that i can't relax and enjoy it because
i'm just
like you know i can't see i get i don't
like when people behind me and that i
just think tony soprano like
i have to you gotta yeah you gotta be
aware of everything one can be behind me
at any time like my it's not out of my
peripheral vision like i don't
like i don't like it but i'm like what's
the face he's making too like
that's scary because i think it's so
important and then you want to make out
with me like now i'm
oh yeah yeah and now i'm grossed out
like but you know
so it's like you would have them eat
your ass but then you don't want to kiss
them after they've been doing that
i don't think so i'm good i'd rather not
i'd rather not as he would say like i
think this is so important to talk about
because i think that so much of our like
shame and embarrassment
and like weirdness comes from this
fake news about what we think we're
supposed to be doing
like i think the hottest shit you can do
is just missionary sex
yeah like i'm i'm very old school
hot take and let them know you don't
know what you're doing i think that's
that's
that's pretty hot oh guys love that what
is this yeah
that's the thing what are you doing
what's that
yeah no that's like that's how i lost my
virginity it was great it was just like
that it was like i don't know what i'm
doing she's like
you got this it was it was my friend too
so it was crazy
it was like i was 18 and she was like
you need to lose your virginity i was
like i know
she was like do you want me to do i was
like yeah that would be the best thing
you can do as a friend
and thanks right thanks friend and so
like that's how it happened that was our
conversation
you just knocked it out yeah it was you
just were like let me get this
yeah because i was really awkward back
in school like the way
still still yeah i mean a lot better
than what i used to be but like growing
up
you're incredibly you guys are so famous
and rich incredibly endearing and
charming
yeah i was like especially the way i
grew up like back and forth between two
religious households
really what religions scientology
and nexium islam and uh
interesting are you either now
no i i don't like to i don't put myself
in religion
at all right now because like see
because those are completely different
religions and i think that's made me
not want to be a part of anything
because they both have completely
different rules and
both both religions and what our sins
are both like wrong it's like fucked up
that's not how it should be
right so to me it's like oh there's no
way that god or whoever is was like this
is the religion that you need to follow
because this it's fucked up the things
that you're not uh
and it's true but but the biological
basis for uh religion
is always really interesting to me
because humans do better when they have
rules to follow yeah
they just i noticed it i was
touring this weekend and i was so happy
touring and i realized it was because
productivity and cooperation makes
dopamine and there were all these rules
you have to wear your mask you have to
be six feet away from people
you can't shake it there's it takes away
all the like do we shake do we not
right before the rigidity i'm not saying
it's good i'm not pro
pandemic not great but i found my i get
very
comfortable and i feel very safe when
there's just rules everyone's following
and i'm not in a constant state of
what's that guy doing why is he so close
to me why did he
do you know what i mean it's like yeah
it takes away a lot of anxiety
and wondering what's gonna happen next
because the rules are already set
right it's just like the knowing like
what you're saying like on tour when you
have a like an itinerary
that's right like i know what's gonna
happen i know that i'm not
someone's not going to hit me or knock
me over because no one can come within
six feet of me and i was like oh this
is what people um part of what why
religion is so soothing
because we have a plan and i know what's
gonna happen and we have rules and i
noticed it when
um a friend of mine uh when my dad died
uh uh and a friend of mine's dad had
died and in the jewish religion like
there's a whole plan in place
when someone dies people bring food over
and they mourn for 30 days and then they
go
like there's a plan a structure of what
to do and when you're grieving
right all you want is just to be told
what to do and where to go and how to do
it because
you have no emotional energy to make
decisions so people are like
what can i do and you're like now i have
to tell you what to do i'm sobbing in
the corner
that's interesting that you have a time
limit for morning just to like so
because on the 31st day you're just like
okay now i can get back to work because
i already did my 30 years but you're
growing out your beard for a year so
it's like you're still doing something
and you're still
like it's just here's a schedule of what
your emotions are going to be
here's this and everyone already starts
it's like and then host mates is they
people start delivering you food the
next day
yeah it's like it's a machine that like
kicks in a premeditated it's like a
production schedule that just
runs itself nobody liked just the one
set of rules so they came up with a
bunch of set of rules
it's like it's great yeah it is really
interesting it's fascinating and we do
well when we know what's going to happen
next
and and also religion has killed more
people than anything ever and causes
wars and all sorts of other bad shit yes
of course
but i just i'm i'm that was just yeah
fascinating that you said that yeah so i
so the way i grew up was very weird
and i didn't know what was right and
what was wrong i didn't know how to talk
to people because i didn't know if
that was the right thing to do and so
and especially because
your parents are like have the
contrasting beliefs
yeah so it's like you have the other
person saying the other person is right
and wrong and then
you grew up around a lot of fighting um
well no
it was uh they were mainly divorced so
they divorced when i was like around
three four and it was the was it you're
going back and forth
it wasn't my fault that they got support
yeah uh no religion 100 percent
like my dad and my mom are on completely
different levels
i can't even believe they got married
yeah yeah unbelievable so this is so you
you don't you this is part of your
thing with marriage yeah yeah that's i
never thought of it like that but yeah
that makes sense
yeah there's part of that's part of your
fear because
you're not gonna you're not gonna do it
but that's not what you're gonna do yeah
i mean i'm not gonna find you're not
gonna have their marriage
yeah exactly like you can release that
yeah you know like you're not gonna do
what they did i mean
the tv show that you your parents
watched of me was the show about that
i was the character was terrified of
getting married because she grew up
around so much divorce
i'm gonna watch it by the way uh and by
the way if you get married and get
divorced that's okay too
yeah of course you'll be fine getting
married for three years
and getting a divorce is a success
that's why i that that's why i wish
marriage wasn't a thing because
if anything just make it a breakup you
broke up and that's it it's a breakup
either way but also
why why not but also then why not get
married
yeah what's your what's your thoughts on
just marriage overall it's fun it's it's
it um i think that marriage is
um my deal with it
is i like to do things the way they are
not
always done so the
formula we've done is you meet someone
you love them
a year and a year and a half in you get
engaged you're engaged for a year we
have all these like socially constructed
timelines that are completely
fabricated right and then you have a kid
and that's the order we go in
and about half of marriages end in
divorce
and then we don't know of the half that
don't end divorce are actually happy so
we have no idea
what that equation is yielding in terms
of successful relationships we have no
idea right
right but we know 50 percent end and i
know a lot of people that are still
married but they're separated but they
just haven't finalized the divorce and i
know a lot of people that
are not legally married who have been
together for 10 years who are
basically married feel married and you
know what i'm saying so it's like
i'm big on like how do we customize this
system
and also kate blanchett married her guy
after 30 days and they've been together
for
18 years wow you know what i'm saying
that's great so there's just wild shit
like that so for me
there's nothing more um
terrifying to me than the idea of
marrying the wrong person even though
we have legalzoom.com it's very easy to
get divorced now it's fine i would be
fine
um there's a lot of like stigma i think
for women and not being married by a
certain age
i was engaged and broke it off so i have
a little bit of like
well i got asked yeah like i'm not an
old spinster
like someone wanted me like i feel
better like i feel like
i should have some kind of like like
like how you're pre-approved for a loan
like i should have i should have some
kind of ring that's like i was asked
yeah like i just want you guys to know i
was asked
somebody wanted america same thing same
diff
um but i think that for us i think
there's some
and i'm also a devil's advocate person
and i think there's something super punk
rock about doing something super risky
that's what i do i like to take risks
and i like to beat the odds and i like
to go like
okay but i'm gonna be the one that does
it you know that's how i've
succeeded in all parts of my life like
this thing can't be done well i'm gonna
do it
and i've failed a lot but i also like
yeah these tried but also
when you try to go for the impossible
thing you have the least amount of
competition
if you try to go for the kind of
possible thing you have way more
competition
if you go for the insanely impossible
there's gonna be less people trying to
get it
so it's like i'm a little bit like dude
i can
i think it would be super punk rock to
get married
um at some point but i don't
i just don't see myself doing it
in a conventional way if that makes any
sense but i think that for most people
you guys get attention all the time for
most people
their wedding is their biggest youtube
video ever
that's like their day they have the
photo you're on camera all the time
that's the one day they all get to be a
youtube star they
all get cameras there so i think a lot
of times when
people that are public figures sort of
like roll their eyes at weddings it's
like well you get to have a wedding
every day
every day you're on camera every day you
get photos taken of you that's true
you know that is a good way to put it
it's like they people like you know what
i'm saying so it's like i think it's
like i don't want to get be elitist and
being like well i don't need a commander
it's like i'm in here and makeup every
fucking day
i get to wear a dress every fucking day
you know yeah but i also think that
as public figures there's something of
the person you're with
i think if they want to be
you to be publicly married to them
as like a form of like respect and
letting people know
because of dm culture i think there's
something cool about that
yeah i think there's something dope
about a guy that i'm going to be with
anyway going i want people to know your
marriage
so that they know how to act yeah and i
think that's right
and i think i need to know how to act
because i am really
um flirty and i'm really like fall in
love with people
like like i totally fall in love with
you guys when you're here like i'm in
love with you
do you know what i mean yeah but and i
think that it's a way to just kind of
like
make sure everybody holds you
accountable
yeah do you know what i mean yeah your
behavior changes if you're married
the rules you like love rules and then
everyone else knows the rules
so my friend kevin christie um brilliant
said to me once i was like i don't want
a wedding he goes the wedding's not for
you
the wedding is so that you invite all
your friends there
and now you're not gonna cheat because
they're in everybody's watch now
they all spent money that's really funny
so now you're gonna behave better
because you're fucking
we're watching you right we're all gonna
hold you accountable when we go out to
the bar and you start flirting with
someone we're like dude
you're married i just spent three
hundred dollars to go to santa barbara
to your fucking wedding
and you're gonna flirt with this chicken
head like it's a way
to make use be a good person i like that
not interesting that is a really cool
way to put that
i'm gonna feel a lot better in my
wedding i'm just gonna be like
i'm not gonna do it but you're gonna get
it paid for it's all gonna be free
you're gonna get content it's not like
why jake paul is famous because he got
married tinder is paying for both of our
weddings anyways because they love both
of us oh my gosh
i bet what else
what else i really could talk to you
guys forever i'm really enjoying this
how are you feeling this is great
um a lot better i was definitely i was
definitely really nervous the first like
few
as you can see why what did you think
was gonna happen um i think because i'm
on someone else's
show because you're wearing shorts in my
studio yeah that too i kept putting my
knees up i'm like oh
no i'm like why am i looking at your
fucking knees yeah wild
um yeah i'm not comfortable with
being on stuff that i'm not like like i
don't know you're not in control yeah
you're out of control yeah you're not in
control you're used to being a hundred
percent in control
yeah it's weird being in the passenger
seat but when i'm out of control oh my
goodness i don't know what to do with my
hands when's your birthday november 18th
nice when's yours april 5th nice oh i
thought you're going to ask i don't i'm
not excited
i'm not i'm no no i'm not that person i
just am like
i just am curious i do think it matters
but not because of astrology
i do think your birthday does matter i
think that the the
month that you had your birthday in does
form your personality
but not because of stars i would i would
love to see analytics of that like i
really want to know because there's
people like that swear by horoscope
is that a turn off if a girl is uh into
astrology
i want to know that that's what that's
what i want i don't i don't think that
would be a turn off i would this is what
i want to give the
girls listening what else is a turn off
to you don't don't
judge yourself say it be honest the
kindest thing you can do for women is
just say what actually turns you off
even if it's like
fucked up buck teeth
[Laughter]
mustache hairy arm hairy nipples that's
real
um if you saw hair on a girl's nipples
like what happens
it is it's a bot like it's just like
yeah it's not there forever
i don't think it's bad you know it could
have been something like they missed
you know what i mean like if they
normally would shave it and then they
just like miss it it's like fuck it you
tweeze those yeah
right yeah
and i always notice on myself too like
if i see a hair on a girl's nipple i'm
just like there's hair on my nipple too
yeah but i'm just like yeah but there's
also hair around your dick i hope
yeah yeah yeah you're not shaving your
pieces right no no no i
do shave your poops what do you do my
boobs your boobs
my boobs i try to keep them perky and
nice you know i don't want to embarrass
but
so what so you shave your balls um
every once in a while everyone yeah
manscaped i'm the manscaping
yeah yeah yeah yeah
promo code whitney but no i mean that's
for real that's legit so what do you
shave just your balls
my balls i get like the sh oh you really
just want to know in detail
which out of your pussy did you tell me
that dude i lasered that shit
ten years ago first that first check
though
second i got money i got the hpv vaccine
and uh lasered my whole crevice
she she keeps asking because she wants
to know if she should get a hair
transplant down there
do you like it more shaved or hairy she
says pink pussy hair
so no i i no i i'm completely lasered
um freezing cold at all times
um but but after a while like little
random like smithers hairs will grow
in like one long hair you know fuck that
you pay for this shit you gotta just get
it yeah you tweeze it
yeah but i'm of the i lasered so that it
never comes back
yeah i heard like it doesn't work all
the time but that's great
somewhere you got no i had to go i had
to do seven sessions i think
like over like once a month for like
seven or eight times yeah
that sounds really bad yeah and dude and
i i mean yeah
yeah welcome to being a fucking woman
all we do is fucking
electrocute ourselves and fry ourselves
and set ourselves on fire so you'll fuck
us
yeah no shit shit you'll be you'll be
surprised what we do with our bodies
what do you do you don't you shave
just like take my dick and stretch it
out every morning i'm just kind of sick
do you jerk off a lot uh no i wouldn't
say i do yeah no i think this next
generation of guys really aren't jerking
off that much
the younger generation jerking off they
do it constantly
huh no you said you like i think the
younger generation is jerking off or not
jerking off as much i was like
i really haven't put much thought into
the younger generation jerking off so
let's talk about
kids um no but but the guys i know in
their 20s aren't like
like jerking off constantly that i i
mean at least
what i understand i also think it's like
just getting older yeah
like i know when like i first started
out it was no joke like
eight times a day i think it's something
i was thinking about this like when i
was in my 20s i really
took guys jerking off as a rejection of
me
like jerking off is not personal to
women it's like it's like taking a piss
it's like you guys just get it over with
it's a
it's not you're not abandoning it you're
not cheating on us
absolutely not i feel like also it's
like i'm not gonna bother with it i'm
just gonna
i'm just gonna do it real quick because
we need to leave you know it's like yeah
it's
it's a hassle yeah yeah it's a box you
have to check
yeah it's not like it's not even that
enjoyable frankly
it's like something like a personal
sydney it's like something you have to
get over with yeah
it took me a long time to understand
that and it's like popping is there or
something
like a format like offended almost like
you would rather do that oh my god if
a guy jerked yes if a guy jerked off
when we were dating
i thought i was like you weren't
satisfying or
yes providing enough because because
there weren't podcasts where guys were
talking and i could find out
the truth girls don't have like those
like feel
have those moments in the moment where
it's like i need to get that started
right yeah the urge is just
get it out of the way if you hit this
table sorry
it's because i don't hear it you don't
hear it
no but i still want to abuse him i still
it's not about whether you can hear an
actually problem is this something you
just want to keep on fucking this isn't
even actually a problem because you know
i get nervous i get stiff when i'm like
hitting the table and you're like you
like to watch me suffer
okay what happens in silence with you
can you be silent right now just silent
look what happens what comes up like if
you're home alone just like
no like if you're around someone and
you're just silent
hello what what what is this question
just be silent are you cool
stop talking oh yeah let's get it
[Music]
i get nervous you get uncomfortable i'm
super nervous with silence yeah
i think because that's your mind just
constantly being like i'm
an entertainer i need to constantly be
so if we're all on our phones right now
would that make you awkward
oh i feel when people take their phones
out i mean maybe this is my
age or my or my gen i don't know but i
feel rejected when someone checks their
phone around i'm getting better about it
but it's i feel abandoned with people
you know
very well
and it's probably a projection because i
know that when i check my phone it's to
check
out do you have cholera
i keep burping and i'm trying to like
keep it low-key but
do you have whooping cough
this is just bubbly he just says are you
missing a septum
because of your cocaine because she
forced drinks on our throat when we
walked in
you take as many as you want he keeps
like coughing
i don't know i'm burping it's just like
these tiny burp bubbles and i'm trying
not to like burp your way
and i'm just like it's really cute
sorry about that um it's just nervous
i don't think you guys are nervous
anymore no i feel great i'm good what
are you gonna do after this
um probably check on that video
this entire time all you've been doing
is thinking about uploading your video
i've been feeling like not fully he's
just like that is your addiction that's
feening that is feening i have a problem
with no i'm just saying
that that we are addicted to things
being completed but that is your drug
that's i'm not it's i'm not saying this
in a negative way it's a good dr i think
the key to life solving fixing life or
your life
is healthy addictions lucrative
addictions you guys found a lucrative
addiction that didn't destroy your life
because you're sitting here like a
fucking crackhead wanting to go
upload that video i think it's uploaded
but i'm gonna take my phone real quick i
mean that wild
wild he cannot control himself this is
wild
okay all right i'm checking right now oh
i have to go i'm doing it
it's up yeah let me see
oh it just got uploaded too that's why
my body
that you knew like your body knew when
it was uploaded
did you just come yeah i did
wild all right we always had lisa
awkwardly what else do you guys want to
say i mean you guys are famous you don't
need me to promote anything for you
um do we need to promote you you don't
need my help um i think just
don't dm him i don't like to i don't i
don't like to promote
like stuff of mine on other people's
stuff you don't need to i think if you
don't that'll actually make people go
look up your stuff
if you promote it people
yeah don't follow them don't google them
but damn who are these moms
no they know i feel like you showed a
different side of yourself today
i think i did too not knowing you at all
and knowing nothing about you i feel
like this was a side i've never seen
yeah and i thought we were going to talk
about something completely different but
we uh
no like normally when heath and iron are
on podcast we talk about like our work
and youtube and all that but we talked
about something completely i literally
would be bored out of my mind
couldn't care less so i'm glad that we
went this route yeah
i was able to be real because i also
think with podcast my approach is always
like
people are going to watch this for in
many ways but
people are going to be googling you on
podcasts and if you talk about the same
thing on every podcast
like they're watching you repeat
yourself like when i go to podcast and
someone's like so is it hard to be woman
comedy i'm like i've already answered
that on another podcast
the person watching has already heard
this answer i'm not gonna and then that
just shows that they didn't do their
research on you and it's just like oh
i'm an asshole now i'm repeating my now
i'm a hack
exactly and you yeah you didn't look me
up and i'm disrespecting the time of the
person that just googled me because
they've already heard this or will hear
it on the next video
yeah you have to ask me something
different yeah
so that's why we're here today to tell
you that i was on synthetic heroin and
he was on cocaine
before we uh but it is possible to beat
and quit
and uh yeah what are your parents names
mark and corey mark and corey thanks for
having this kid
oh she thinks they made it to the end of
the video that was really cool
thanks for having him by accident
oh shit that's so funny don't write
elephants you guys i love you
i really enjoyed this and
didn't really think i would wasn't sure
like i knew i wouldn't i knew i would
learn a lot from you guys but i didn't
think i would feel so
um like hopeful you guys like have
filled me with like
cool hope and joy i feel like uh like
relieved
yeah i feel like i just said that this
is over yeah right exactly exactly
no it felt like almost like venting like
it was nice it just felt like
like i could have been here for another
five hours talking first yeah we'll do
i'm sure we will do that at some point
um but i'm i feel like hopeful and like
this has been very healing for me
you might not know you might not know
why or care why it doesn't matter why
but i feel like
for women that are going like men suck
and men are the worst and men
hurt women and and it's men are the like
you guys are what we've been
waiting this is what we've wanted it's
happened
zippered
oh shit i'm brittany this is tiffany and
we just
and this was our biggest prank oh
[Music]
[Applause]